.
AS THE ALARMS GO OFF.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
APPRECIATE IT.
>>> WITH US NOW IS FORMER U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE, BILL
TAYLOR.
BILL -- MR. AMBASSADOR THANKS
FOR JOINING US.
U.S. DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE JUST WARNED
CONGRESS AS THE WAR DRAGS ON IT
IS LIKELY TO BECOME, QUOTE, MORE
UNPREDICTABLE AND ESCALATORY.
DO YOU AGREE?
>> I DO, JAKE.
IT'S HARD TO SAY WHAT'S GOING
THROUGH PUTIN'S MIND.
NO ONE REALLY KNOWS.
HE'S GOT NO GOOD OPTIONS.
HE DEMONSTRATED THAT THAT FAMOUS
SPEECH A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO, ON
VICTORY DAY, WHERE HE DID
ANNOUNCE DOUBLING DOWN.
HE DIDN'T ANNOUNCE STANDING DOWN
WITH SOME VICTORIES, HE DIDN'T
HAVE ANY VICTORY.
HE WAS WORRIED ABOUT DOUBLING
DOWN AND CALLING UP THE
RESERVES.
BUT BECAUSE THAT WOULD EXPOSE
THE LIE THAT HE'S NOT REALLY
FIGHTING.
SO HE DOESN'T HAVE GOOD OPTIONS.
AND SO, NO ONE REALLY KNOWS WHAT
HE DOES.
>> DNI ALSO WARNED THERE ARE
INCREASING CHANCES IN HER VIEW
THAT PUTIN COULD IMPOSE MARSHAL
LAW IN RUSSIA.
PUTIN'S SPOKESPERSON DENIES
THAT.
HOW STABLE ARE THINGS IN RUSSIA
OR HOW UNSTABLE?
>> REALLY UNSTABLE.
AGAIN, HE'S PROBABLY WORRIED.
PRESIDENT PUTIN IS PROBABLY
WORRIED.
HE'S GOT SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
10,000 AND 20,000 RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS WHO HAVE BEEN KILLED IN
UKRAINE.
WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THOSE RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS KILLING CIVILIANS JUST
NOW AND HORRIFYING.
BUT 10,000 TO 20,000 HAVE BEEN
KILLED AND ARE GOING BACK FOR
BURIAL IN PLACES AROUND RUSSIA.
SO THERE'S DISCONTENT.
THERE'S REAL PROBLEMS.
THERE'S ECONOMIC PROBLEMS CAUSED
BY THE SANCTIONS.
SO PUTIN DOESN'T HAVE GOOD
OPTIONS AND THE MARSHAL LAW WILL
PROBABLY BE DESTABILIZING,
RATHER THAN STABLEIZING.
>> THEY ALSO SAID THAT RUSSIA IS
READY TO TAKE OVER A REGION OF
UKRAINE IF THAT'S WHAT THE
PEOPLE WANT.
OBVIOUSLY RUSSIAN FORCES CONTROL
MUCH OF THE AREA OF KHERSON.
HOW CAN THOSE REQUESTS TO JOIN
RUSSIA BE SEEN AS A FREELY MADE
DECISION BY ANYONE ELSE IN THE
WORLD?
>> CLEARLY NOT.
THERE'S NO WAY IT WILL BE SEEN
AS A FREELY MADE DECISION.
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID.
IF THEY DO THAT, IF THEY TRY TO
DO THAT, THEY'VE DONE IT BEFORE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID IN DONBAS,
IN DONESK AND LUHANSK.
JUST LIKE IN CRIMEA, NO ONE
BELIEVES THEM.
NO ONE ACCEPTS WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO.
THE UKRAINIANS WILL NEVER GIVE
UP CLAIM TO THOSE LANDS.
IT'S UKRAINIAN LAND.
>> LET'S TURN TO THE ECONOMIC
ASPECTS OF THE WAR THE
UKRAINIANS SAID THEY'VE BEEN
FORCED TO SUSPEND SHIPMENTS OF
RUSSIAN NATIONAL GAS GOING
THROUGH PIPELINES IN UKRAINE,
COMPLAINING IT ENDANGERED THE
SYSTEM'S SAFETY AND STABILITY.
HOW MUCH TROUBLE COULD THIS
CAUSE IN EUROPE IF IT CONTINUES?
>> WELL, FORTUNATELY, JAKE, IT'S
SPRING.
AND FORTUNATELY THAT MEANS THAT
THE HEATING SEASON IS NOW OVER.
SO DEMAND FOR THAT GAS GOES
DOWN, IS GOING DOWN.
AND THERE ARE A GOOD NUMBER --
THERE'S BEEN A MOUNTAIN OF
RESERVES OF GAS TO TAKE THEM
THROUGH THE SUMMER INTO THE
FALL.
THEY SHOULD BE RESUPPLYING,
REPLENISHING THOSE RESERVES.
SO THAT WILL BE AN ISSUE THEY
HAVE TO LOOK AT.
BUT THE UKRAINIANS KNOW THESE
PIPELINES GO THROUGH AREAS THAT
THE RUSSIANS CONTROL, THEY
OCCUPY, AND THEY ARE BLEEDING